okay it's time for hatred mail and I
have a new hatred mail introduction to a
debut for you today let's take a listen
to this together this one partially
inspired by members of our audience new
intro because we don't care about
liberal [ __ ] so much that we spend our
time writing to them patriot man written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom we
really have to get David Pakman show
bingo going soon because this hatred
mail would would probably be bingo for
many people in the audience let's take a
listen David Pakman is an Argentinean
Jewish white male who is so heterosexual
him and his rosy-cheeked sidekick pad
only went to the movies as friends once
rights
Parkman is a soy progressive faux
progressive the real question is how
tall is David Pakman can't be more toxic
than you soy boy Pakman I like that I'm
a soy progressive faux progressive that
is now it's an amalgamation basically of
the last two years of sort of beta male
inspired insults in this entire soy boy
thing soy progressive faux progressive I
should if only you could get that on a
license plate Pat that's what my vanity
license plate would be yeah and I'm rosy
cheeked Pat is that even an insult is
that some sort of like homophobic slur
Lee that he's using there no they're
just referring to the white balance on
your camera and lighting don't don't
worry about that we'll get that taken
care of after the show if you want to
send a middle finger to the hey tree
'it's use the coupon code hey tree at 40
okay when you go to our website
www.jfn.co.jp/toho at 40 everybody wins
other than the hey tree 'it's you win
because you save 40 percent off of your
membership the David Pakman show wins
because we grow our revenue
sources through viewer support and hey
tree 'it's lose because it's like a
middle finger to the hey tree it's when
you use the coupon code hey tree at 40
so do that please I consider it a
personal favor and more hatred mail next
week we actually have I just got a few
hours ago a couple of new hatred mails
which we'll be using in the next couple
of weeks they make today's look like
nothing let me just say that